welcome to care BTW thank you I'm happy
to be here so glamorous right for
entertainment tonight it is it like look
at all the sparkles back here and you
know as this fairy lights there was no
expense when it came to our booth for
but you had unlimited budget absolutely
i've never been to camp um I doesn't
like this like yes but no like yes I
have no it doesn't look at NASA so
VidCon had an actual camp who like what
other YouTube crater would be your bunk
buddy um Jack oh yeah he's actually my
funk buddy now is he really from
Australian he's staying at my place oh
yeah gotta keep it going there is hahaha
yeah I love it so this is my first time
at VidCon okay you're a regular second
time second time second time I haven't
been in like the I guess you could say
social media world by a long time I've
lived in LA for years yeah so like I
moved here than VidCon was right after I
moved last year and yeah but you
mentioned you ran into some fans right
yeah yeah walking through well thank you
we looked like how do i survived VidCon
there's a lot of people with selfie
sticks ready to go well I'm be ready
like you have your hair done so like
you're ready um have you been facing as
well thank you uh but yeah so you said
you haven't been in the social media
game in a while but like they're really
embracing you especially the YouTube
community what do you think um it is
really it is a blessing and it is
awesome just to see where things are
going and how things are happening I
didn't know like I knew they were you
like youtubers so I would say like three
years ago um and I didn't know like
social media was a thing and I've always
wanted to act that's I've been I've been
acting since I was like in middle school
you know doing theatre and here on that
theater kids yes skicka Joss Joss
exactly that there we go theater camp
there we go thanks for coming in some
poor choice or as a juice box cheers to
VidCon yes
Oh